hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do some CSS work just like we did
two days ago on the live stream so we're
gonna style a different part of a
different template but it'll be the same
same basic process we're gonna check out
what the mark-up looks like that we're
given so we although we do have control
over the mark-up there's we would have
to edit it in a lot of different places
so it will make more sense for us to
just style it as is for now to get
things ready for launch and then
afterwards we can think about okay now
that we have more time what's the ideal
format for this content and then we can
change it or hopefully more likely I can
get some some student workers so since
we're doing this project for a
university we can get some student
workers to to format the data properly
since that's something that you know you
could be trained to do on one or two of
them and then do the rest you know
really without supervision so that's the
plan today I expect to do for the stream
to be maybe like an hour an hour and a
half I will warn everybody the last hour
or so I've started to feel like not
really good I hope I'm not getting sick
but to be honest with you I didn't eat
anything for a long time this morning
and I just had coffee and then I ate a
bunch of gummy bears and then since I'm
so smart I ate chocolate after that and
then I decided to eat real food so it's
probably my own fault for eating
like at nothing and then eating junk
food so anyway hopefully I'm alright I
apologize if through my own folder I get
really sick jokes is great diet yet I
know it's a terrible diet I am I was
talking with somebody another developer
on Instagram and they were talking about
this bulletproof coffee I don't know if
you ever heard of it but I had tried it
a long time ago it's like coffee mixed
with butter and like coconut oil or like
other will that's like basil coconut oil
right you you blend it all up and and
then you drink it and it's supposed to
it's supposed to like induce ketosis
which like gets energy right to your
brain a lot better and you feel full
after you drink it you don't need to eat
so I said I was up at like 2 o'clock in
the morning so this was really her this
is like 3 o'clock in the morning I said
you know what like I think I'm gonna try
it and then later on when I took the
kids to school I said ok I'm gonna go to
store and get all the stuff and then I'm
gonna try it I won't eat and then I'll
I'll let you know how it goes
so that was my plan and it went pretty
low until I ate all the junk food and
then after that I've started to feel not
so good so I don't know if it was the
bulletproof coffee or the junk food I'm
guessing it is probably more like the
junk food but the coffee itself was
pretty good so anyway let me get started
enough about my terrible diet today
we're gonna get started for those of you
who are new to the stream this is the
format I do my normal everyday work that
so I'm a front-end developer I work
full-time for a small university we're
working on the university's main website
of transfer
bring it from an old content management
system to a react based system so right
now we're just gonna work on some CSS
and that part of it but if you want to
see the whole process start to finish
there's I think this is video number 54
so we've done quite a lot to get to this
point so it's totally understandable if
you have questions then feel free to ask
you know as many questions as you want
and it looks like there's some problems
with the stream what is the issue with
the stream alright not sure what's going
on with the stream hopefully y'all can
still at least hear me the video might
be choppy now I'm trying to figure out
what's what's messing this up right now
but anyway we split things up into
Pomodoro session so I'm gonna do 25
minute session where I mostly code don't
really look at the live chat too often
and then I'm gonna take a break I'm
gonna answer questions in the live chat
and then we'll do another 25 minute code
session and then after that we'll take
the whole rest of the stream to answer
answer questions so we're definitely
beginner friendly so don't feel like you
know your this isn't the place for your
question it definitely is and we'll do
our best to help you out give you an
answer or at least try to let you know
where you could find an answer okay it
looks like the stream is back it's back
up uh it seemed like the internet almost
just like cut out it's possible somebody
else in my I'm working for home right
now somebody else in my house might have
been playing like YouTube or Netflix and
mess it up all John says it could be the
weather yeah ice that's true it's been
really windy lately around here and I
know like I haven't had a power outage
yet but there have been power outages
elsewhere so that certainly could be
affecting things alright so let me make
this bigger cuz I
this is way too small for anyone to see
and let's start the Pomodoro session
it's probably still too small let's make
it a little bigger
there we are and actually I was doing a
little bit of work on the server file so
let me commit what I've done there
before we get started okay I did do a
little bit of extra work styling the
page we were working on on the last
stream so nothing major if you want to
know what what else I've done check out
the latest few commits the link for this
repository is in the description
so we're just doing a basic git add if
you're familiar with git if you're not
familiar with git this is just a way to
track all the changes that happen in
your code that way everybody else can
see the progress but you can also if you
mess something up you could very easily
revert back to a previous state in the
project so that's why we use git and so
I'm just saving the project at this
particular stage with a little note
about what change in the project that'll
give us like a nice like save point to
go forward and that way if we really
mess anything up we can always just go
right back to this point so I get it's
good if you're familiar with like video
games and they have a save point at the
game in the middle of a level or
something like that's a good way to like
basically think of git is creating lots
of little save points in your project
that you can easily go back to oops yarn
let's see alright so if you notice the
stuff going on in the terminal is a
little bit slow that's because of the
the streaming software that I'm using
that it shouldn't be that slow on your
machine
unless maybe you have a really slow
machine already so let's okay alright so
while that does its thing we can get
started with me showing you all what
we're gonna be working on today so let
me move this over to this screen area
okay so this is a department page so the
last time we were working on a major
page for a major or program so
originally I coded a major page but I've
come to find out that actually the the
better term to use is program so if you
hear me use those words interchangeably
then I mean they mean the same thing for
us for this project so this is a
department page and in the department
pages we now have this section here
which is links let me show you what it
looked like on the site let's see I have
this open on another screen or I did
there we are so here's the site as it is
right now the old version of the site I
didn't want it to be on a different
screen oh well so we thought we already
have this section that's that we brought
over and that looks fine this section
we're just gonna leave out for now the
core curriculum has been around for a
while I don't think we need to say
anything say this on everything
Department page we already have all this
data saved as a post type so we're gonna
put this in but we're not gonna worry
about that today in the same way with
videos we have a lot of these videos
already saved I I don't think we have
them categorized yet but once we get
them categorized it'll be pretty easy to
pull these in and display them on the
proper pages so all we're worried about
today is getting this data that shows up
here you know in this little Block in
this menu and now we're gonna try to
take so this is what what has come
through which looks a lot different than
how it's displayed otherwise and we're
gonna try to style this in a way that
makes sense
and that is going to be able to be
applied you know cross the board on all
these department pages so first things
first
let's check out what markup we have here
I mean already looking at it I'm seeing
that everything is repeated there's the
actual link and then there's the I guess
the title which it looks like they're
the same so we ought to be able to just
completely hide this text title and then
just keep the links and style those how
we want it to style them so let's see
how this is and I'm gonna let me make
this a lot bigger for you all so I'm
sure it's not that easy to read let's
see if we can go up one more okay that
should work and I'm gonna move this down
a bit but let's let's make this very
small there we are
that'll give us a lot of space here so
hold on my music and my headphones is
really loud it's distractingly loud so
let me turn it down a bit okay that's
that's better
okay so alright the heading is there the
headings fine it wouldn't be a bad idea
if we act if we did have a heading
though up here we'll have to add that in
so we'll see the primary focus right now
is getting this stout if we have a
little bit of time before the streams
over then maybe we'll make sure that we
get a title here for all the Dept pages
if we're not already using a department
page template then we may even want to
create our own template for that but
well we'll get to that when we need it
and what just happened I don't know why
it refreshed
maybe I click something I'm not sure all
right so the headings fine well I'm
sorry the this h2 is fine for now the
headings here I think we can completely
get rid of and then what we'll keep this
so let's let's hide these so it looks
like there's nothing else with a heading
on this page and I just want to double
check up here make sure there's no title
hiding out here and it looks like
there's not okay yeah so first things
first let's hide all the titles and then
see what we have see what it looks like
obviously we're gonna have to style this
what's this Department Department menu
oh okay
so we we have this data here as well I
don't think I have this data all
together for every department yet but
the plan is to put it all together so
yeah so if we have time maybe we'll work
on this little section here as well it's
displayed as a totally separate part of
this which makes sense like these aren't
programs yes okay so I guess we can we
can test this out right here in our in
our dev tools and so let's go here and
just I'm gonna add this in we're gonna
say display:none there we are
and so that's taking away all of these
we've already we have these break tags
here but I believe we're already
display:none on those so we don't have
those word display:none on these link
tags which is fine that's that's as it
should be
where's my content yeah
the markups messed up it this is just
how it was automatically done in the old
content management system so if you're
looking at this markup and saying like
what is this stuff then you're entirely
right in thinking that it's definitely
not ideal all right
all right let's work on each one of
these is wrapped in an item okay let's
work on this item then and then we can
style the the a tag inside of it one
item if anything I'm doing in dev tools
if you're not sure how I'm doing it just
let me know you know I know if you're
not familiar with dev tools then it may
not really be obvious how this this
stuff's working but I'd be happy to to
explain it so if you put it in the live
chat now I'll get to it as soon as this
Pomodoro session is over which will be
in 15 minutes okay so for the items
let's say display:block and that'll make
this these will all appear click on top
of each other here's different programs
so already that looks a lot better now
let's go here to these eight tags so
there's no other eight tags on the page
right now so well except for down here
which I'm not worried about these yet so
I'm just gonna style these as like just
regular like a tags but what we want to
do though is make sure that when we do
the CSS we only target a tags that are
inside these item tags that should be
specific enough that it it wouldn't
apply like let's say if there happened
to be some inline links that it wouldn't
mess those up all right so we first
thing we want to do is
text-decoration:none that'll get rid of
the underlines let's make sure our font
size is is a decent size so let's do
font size at least 18 pixels there we
are that's nicer to do 18 pixels and my
a huge fan of that color line Heights
point five there we are okay so we're
bumped the line height up to 1.5 which
which gives us a nice spacing here I
don't know that we've decided on a
standard color for links for this site
yet let's see what let's see what colors
we can we were using that gold weren't
we let's see what was it I can't forget
the hex value foot or I can't remember
the hex value for that let's I can grab
the hex value from this header area
we'll grab that and then let's do color
let's give it that gold color and see
how that looks all right what do you all
think gold color for links do you like
it do you not like it is it too light
it definitely matches with the color
scheme or it doesn't stand out as much
but it I think it's okay I think I'm
gonna try to keep it like this that way
you all get a chance to look at it more
I can look at it more and then I'll be
able to get feedback later on to some
other people that I from some other
people that I work with all right so
let's keep it like that so I think the
other things that we've done I can just
remember and put that in the CSS but I'm
gonna copy this since we have a bit more
for this one let's go over to our code
now and let me get rid of some stuff or
shrink some stuff that we really don't
need and let me see I want to make sure
what we're using make sure I'm using the
right template for departments and this
is okay know where we're actually using
the page template for the departments
right now was this the one that we had
trouble with
I see this template we were using some
old styles with okay all right here's
what I'm gonna do we're gonna make if we
don't already have one we're gonna make
a CSS file for department pages and then
on another stream or maybe I'll just do
this on my own we're gonna convert this
to use the latest version of Apollo and
the newer way of getting data from graph
QL which this one is using the old way
when we started this project the the
newer way wasn't available yet so we're
just gonna forget about this for now cuz
I want to keep this mainly about CSS and
we'll work on that later and from now
let's just go in here to our Styles
folder and we're gonna do Department dot
CSS all right so now we have that and
let me do what do we say this would be
item in a tag right it was an aide site
yeah and then we're gonna put that in
there and our indentation is not great
we'll fix that okay and then we have the
headings right yeah our heading is going
to be display:none
and finally we took the each item and we
gave that display blah
okay so I think that was all we did for
a CSS a pretty basic so far and what
will likely end up doing is taking
whatever CSS we have here for page CSS
and we're gonna use that in our
department CSS kind of as a base and
we'll get rid of what we don't need and
we'll change what we do need but for now
I'm gonna put it in here since we will
need it although you'll see in a second
it's really gonna be unnecessary because
what we'll do here in our page template
which is what we're using right now for
department page is temporarily where is
page JSO we want to keep page j s as
like unup enya nated as possible in
terms of style because this is our
default like fallback for content that
we don't really have any specific styles
for so we want it to be able to work
just basically like display text nicely
and not mess things up too much so I
don't want to keep it like what I'm
about to do here for too long but it
should work just for now just to test
things out all right let me check my
time - all right we got time we'll
definitely be able to least see if this
works so I added another link tag you
can see here if you used to just regular
HTML and not necessarily react just
think about like we we have our head tag
and then inside we have our link tags
where we were importing CSS so that part
should be very familiar and so in
addition to page dot CSS I'm gonna put
this department dot CSS file that we
just created alright and that's lower
down so given the cascading nature of
cascading style sheets of CSS this will
override whatever is here okay so you
can see why everything we just copied
over its kind
pointless right now because right we
already have it on the page but this way
it'll just be one less thing that we
have to remember to do when we do split
this out you this component and update
it so that it'll work with what we're
kind of like the latest stuff that we're
doing with Apollo if you're interested
in the updates that have to do with the
latest version of Apollo we did a stream
on that a while back so you just kind of
scroll back through through the playlist
of what is it project 5 playlists you
should see some streams about Apollo
like upgrading and and that way you'll
get the latest so if you have use Apollo
before but you're not really up on the
new things that'll be kind of a nice
dream because we don't cover everything
Apollo does just the latest stuff just
the changes and just kind of go over how
we update existing Apollo code to that
that latest stuff you can see here like
we're using this query element this
query component ok so let's say that
make sure to save it and just want to
make sure I saved this as well I think I
did but it has happened before that I've
thought that my code wasn't working and
the real problem was that I never saved
it alright so we're gonna go back here
and we're gonna hit refresh and
hopefully all our Styles still stay
alright wonderful it works let's double
check and make sure that all our styles
are working and they're not being you
know overridden by anything so does it
looks like yeah all these work obviously
the things that we've set to
display:none are displayed on and we
don't have to test that we can just see
and our display block is working on our
items the only thing that's different is
now we see that these eight
eggs don't have the styling that we
applied so this is this might be a good
time to apply as a standard for all
eight eggs the text-decoration:none and
this color so let's go back and do that
now at least at the very least we can do
that in in this file and then maybe in
our page I am gonna have to sort we are
we do have some global styles I don't
want to get into that though cuz this is
for basic CSS so for those of you that
are more familiar with react and
material UI and what's going on with our
project the better place to put this
what we're about to do is probably in
those like the global styles that we we
have coming from material UI sorry about
the stream quality here it's kind of
dropping out we're really sorry about
this I've I don't know what's going on
let me double check my machine really
quick cuz there's maybe I have something
running that I just don't I didn't
realize I had running
no I know it might maybe it is my
internet connection all right on one of
my other screens I'm gonna run a speed
test really quick just to see if the
connection is fine then I know it's
something on my computer but if the
connection is bad then I'm not gonna be
able to do anything about it right now
and I may as well just try to continue
as best I can with the stream all right
so speed test is running right now over
here let's just pull out this and we'll
put it for now I'll just put it right
here and all we need really is this
let's save that and then since we had C
we have open
I'm just gonna paste this in a few of
these other places for now okay so let's
save that and let's say this okay be the
upload speed is actually a bit slow
right now
from what I should have so it's possible
that that the Internet is the issue so
hopefully we don't have too many more
issues here all right my timer went off
so let's do it at five minute break here
I'm gonna go back to the the chat I'm
gonna scroll all the way to the top and
just try to work my way down if I don't
get to your question during this break
then just hang on I'll get to it at the
after the next Pomodoro session so hey
right there are a lot of people saying
hi hey everyone thanks for watching
our j-p-d geeks point says why you are
all time I'm not sure what you were
trying to say it seems like maybe there
was a word left out there so if you're
still watching let me know what what you
were trying to ask there I see a few
more you were saying hi asking how it's
going not bad actually I'm feeling
pretty good now it's going well
Danone J says how can I make a page
responsive without using any frameworks
yet media queries so Fenix mentioned
that yeah media queries so let's just
let me show you we have some media
queries going somewhere in here right
where are they
here we go all right so like this you
know so we'd have a media query so right
now this is a little bit of responsive
stuff here so when it's when we have a
small screen okay when we have a small
screen the width of our main container
is 90% but then when the screen gets
bigger than 600 pixels we only display
70% I'd this make sure that our content
isn't spread out really far on wide
screens but then on small screens we
want to make sure that it doesn't have
too much padding and becomes like all
squished and really hard to read so that
was just like a very simple example of
using media queries for responsiveness
so if you're not familiar with media
queries definitely like look up the
syntax and so like mdn is Mozilla
developer Network is a great place to
look up syntax for different web related
things and just copy and paste some of
these for a long long time I could not
remember how to do media queries from
scratch I had to copy and paste them all
the time and even
occasionally I'll forget the exact
syntax so the like don't don't worry
like if you don't get it right away it
so it took me a long time and you know
they're a little tricky
so Lee asked how do you get your
developer tools to be so dark couldn't
find the option okay let's do this real
quick because so if you're in your dev
tools in chrome and you go up here to
this menu this three dots and you click
it you go down here to settings I guess
you can get there by pressing f1 as well
you go to settings right here in
preferences under appearance for me it's
the third option here I'm assuming it'd
be the same for everybody you just go to
the theme and you a dark theme so by
default it's this light theme which is
too bright for me I like the dark theme
dark theme for everything so I switched
it to dark that's a lot nicer I think a
lot easier to look at so that's how you
get the dark theme
see
himemiya says the gold looks good but a
little darker is better
okay cool maybe we'll will mess with the
kind of the darkness therefore that may
be you a little bit darker and make
those links pop a little bit fruity
spirit says how many more sessions are
you going to do in live streams if you
mean sessions and this stream we're
going to do one more Pomodoro session if
you mean sessions as in like live
streams I'm gonna keep doing live
streams till nobody wants them anymore I
guess so for this project I have no idea
how many more streams it's gonna take
but I mean we may like eventually this
project may just turn into more like
maintenance mode and we'll just come
back to it every once in a while and
then we'll move on to another like main
project all right it's let me I'm gonna
stop here and I want to make sure that I
remember where I left off at so I'm
gonna mark this down okay let's go back
here let's do our Pomodoro and we do one
more session I'm refreshing this to make
sure that this is applied okay so that
is applied let's take a look at this
color though and let's see if we can
make it a bit darker so I'm gonna click
this color whoops in dev tools I'm gonna
click on the actual like the the box
that displays the color and if we go in
here and we shift this we can see like
the RGB a but I want to go to the HS
l a and which one are we gonna do you
something is it this one
a life
so if we change this L value what is
this like hue/saturation it's this light
I don't remember what all those are I
can't remember what everything is I'm
not like a designer you know I do some
design stuff but basically this L value
will give us the color will basically be
the same but it just makes it a little
lighter or darker so if we go a little
darker here and then we check it out
see now we have this hsla value and if
that's the value we want if that looks
it definitely looks darker just
comparing it from here to here we can go
with that and we can take this out and
now in our code where do we have this
here so in all the places where we just
had this and we can now change it so
we'll save it there let's save it there
whoops I wanted to completely get rid of
that oh that didn't work out I want it
let's make sure I did it right here I
did and then finally our department CSS
is going to be
there we go
so now everything is that darker value
and if we refresh we should be able to
see what it looks like
even in line
oh no I just saw it said the color the
color picker thing is hidden behind that
my face sorry about that okay but that
definitely is darker okay
so we'll keep it like that for now I
like that idea we've done that in
previous projects before never with this
color but with a different color and it
worked well to make things more readable
alright let's see what were you gonna do
next this part I think we're gonna style
this part next I do want to take this
this title here
hmm yeah this is too much space between
this title and this so let's see let's
go to margin bottom of 8 pixels
all right that's nicer I like that
better give it a font weight of 400 yeah
that's different yeah and then what
colors this
as to our colors and I forgot to write
Archie
okay alright so this is what we're gonna
do for a ch2 title basically what we've
done is we've decreased the margin on
the bottom because before it just kind
of was there it didn't really look like
it belonged to this list we also
decrease the font weight the font weight
was a little heavy it was kind of
overwhelming and it stood out I think
too much on the page and then we also
changed the color so I believe I
couldn't find the value but from looking
at it look like it was solid black we
changed that to be black with an opacity
of 87% and that's what we did here with
the RGB a value and that softens the
black a bit it's still very readable if
you look at it it's like okay that's
still black but it definitely makes a
difference and that's that's the
standard kind of black value for
material design okay well we rarely ever
use like solid black alright so let's
grab this value and let's add it in with
this
all right I need to get like autoformat
for my CSS it would be helpful and I'm
gonna give it a refresh just to make
sure that's all working
okay looks good alright now we can get
down to this part here and we'll style
this a bit so alright Phil let's do it
just like we did with this section first
thing we're gonna do is just see what
we're dealing with in terms of markup
mobile title okay so we definitely
hmm
let me think about it so the first thing
we have here is an apply ply link do we
want the apply I will leave that in for
now yeah we'll leave that in for now I
guess it makes sense to have an apply
button you know down here somewhere link
text
that's odd alright so let me let me just
think out loud for a second here
so these links we have link text as a
separate element but then within the a
tag the name doesn't match up with the
link text so this says classics but what
we really want is classics faculty they
have the summer ancient and Biblical
Languages Institute and that that does
word
okay here's what I'm thinking I'm
assuming and maybe I'm wrong here but
I'm assuming that every department page
has a link to that departments faculty
and that link is gonna follow the same
structure of being name of the
department slash faculty if that's the
case we could do something very similar
to what we did in the last dream where
we didn't use what was given to us from
the markup and instead we created our
own element in reacts that created that
that leg for us and then we didn't have
to use the mark-up that was given to us
that would solve our issue here of
having to somehow use this link text
instead of the text that's within the a
tag so we'll do that and then some our
ancient biblical language is Institute
yeah we definitely need to keep this
and then for the apply link there we
definitely don't need to pull in the
apply link from here we know what that
link is it's gonna be the same on every
page alright this is this is gonna be
tough because I don't even really want
these links I just want to hide these
links and create elements and react for
those but I want this link let me see
you know let me bring over another
example of what's happening here so
let's see let's see what the business
department has are you serious we don't
have a business department page oh I
know what it is it's a weird URL it's
like something like that I just had
oh there's only one see okay all right
so we have the faculty link here and
then we have this MBA 4+1 program
yes
alright I'm gonna check the chat quickly
to see if you all have any any input on
this
all right so
[Music]
yeah binary 64 saying dual Asif site the
only thing I'm thinking is it's not I
think there are some programs that have
more than two here so they'll have
multiple ones so it won't always be last
of type all right I'll just have to
here's what I'm gonna do and I probably
won't do it on the stream right now
because we have ten minutes left and I
just want to stick to CSS but what I'm
going to do longer term I'll just have
somebody going and remove all those
links because we don't need them short
term what we can do is clean the data as
we as it comes in so what we can do is
put a function in in our component that
searches through this data and finds
this apply now and so basically the call
to action stuff we can take that out CTA
link we can take pull that out that's
not gonna be a big deal we can do that
with with CSS and just hide it then for
this one we can take out faculty and we
can take out any a tag that is linking
to faculty right so we're we're just
gonna search for that and remove the
stuff so it'll be a little tricky but
once we get it working like it should be
fine we've done similar things and other
components already and then basically
once we remove those two everything else
that's here will be okay and that will
want to use it so for right now I'm just
gonna style this and just make sure that
you know we get rid of this stuff at
some point
so let's see how we want this to look so
first of all these menu items should be
display:block okay great
and then even hard my menu
yeah we you know what let's keep this
title whoops
display:block and we're gonna font size
let's go 24 pixels and font weight 400
there we go
all right not exactly like this but now
that I look at it this could probably be
made a little bit smaller so I'm okay
with this for now then fine now we're
not gonna worry about these ones we need
to get rid of the link text so anything
that's link text is gonna be
display:none great and then anything
that's an a tag inside of a menu item
which so we can do now like I don't a is
gonna be on weight okay all right so not
bad and remember you know this apply now
won't be there classics won't be there
so essentially the apply button if it is
there it'll say apply this will say
classics faculty
all right no bad so I mean that
basically matches what what we have here
okay so let me move this trying to
remember what we did all right menu
items are displayed on our display block
let's make our CTA text and Link which
one had them oh this one had the most
right all right we'll start with that
okay
menu title and then I'm going a little
bit fast here because I know we're
running out of time for this Pomodoro
section menu item menu item and the CTA
tech CTA link or display:none said
honest
and then menu item a actually let's do
item a and then that should be it I
think that's everything that we did
let's refresh just to be sure
[Music]
nope I forgot one thing and what was
that the item link text that's it
all right so you want to do link text
okay what it is not you know what I
didn't add the weight the correct weight
here font weight 400 there we go all
right so now that's gonna be fine
that'll give us what we wanted should
did I mess up the name for this mobile
title yep I messed up the name
mobile title okay check our time awesome
just in time
okay so I went through that kind of
pretty quickly and what we did with I
just took advantage of when we are
already using those same styles instead
of typing the Styles out again we just
added you know just with some commas we
added in some more element names for our
display:none for a display:block and for
how we style those menu items which are
links the only new stuff we had to add
was this mobile title which really we
probably could have used something
similar to what we're doing here but I
mean overall okay now I say that I mean
that's it's not perfect but it looks a
lot cleaner they look broken before
basically I mean it looked broken if you
remember we had duplicated text all
running across the page now that looks
like it's supposed to be like that you
know whether or not someone thinks that
this is a good way to do it or it's a
pretty way to do it it looks organized
like it was it was meant to be like that
which is better than broke all right
cool so my timers up there I'm gonna get
started with getting this all up to
github and while that's running I'm
gonna go back to the live chat sorry I'm
gonna go back to the live chat and
answer some more questions so first
thing Oh what happened it looks like the
last time I
try to do this it timed out the end end
tests timed out I didn't even notice
that okay alright so let's try this once
again we're gonna retry that last one
hopefully it'll pass so while that's
running I'm gonna scroll back to our
left off at which for me was the
timestamp 2:25 p.m. Eastern Time
hmmm II asked have you tried the new
Adam I have not used Adam in a while so
no I guess not
what's um what's new okay Phoenix is
asking what would I say it Adam
I used to use at him all the time like
for years I used to Adam and I really
liked it
but if you're using it on a computer
that was really fast and powerful it was
fine but it was a little sluggish you
know on on a computer that wasn't so
powerful Visual Studio code seems to be
more performant so it's a little bit
quicker so I've switched to Visual
Studio code I really like it there's a
lot of nice features I mean really in
terms of features it seems like you can
get plugins to do the same thing for
Adam and Visual Studio code if you want
to so it really comes down to the
performance and Visual Studio code does
seem to be a bit quicker even though
Adam and Visual Studio code right both
run on electron for whatever reason you
know the team that worked on Visual
Studio code was able to get better
performance out of it I have heard some
of the reasons why but I'm not gonna get
into them now because to be honest with
you I'm not knowledgeable enough about
electron to even know if those reasons
are reasonable
hmmm he says a stands for anchor yep
yeah it's an anchor tag
okay John says the link styled in the
gold color alone doesn't really say
click me I'm a link okay
it could be missed I'm gonna take that
in consideration I'd like to do at some
point some tests where I can actually
watch users and what they do so I'm
gonna make sure I I think about that
when I'm watching them so basically I
like to just have users sit down
and I tell them nothing about the site
and I just want to watch what they do
first where they go where they scroll
what they click so if I notice that
users are clicking on things that are
gold then probably it's not gonna be a
big issue but if I notice that they're
always scrolling past and never clicking
then I think we'll have to well think
about changing the color or at the very
least changing the color of the links
that we really want users to click on
like apply and donate would be the the
two major links that we want people to
click on and did it did it again alright
so the tests aren't really failing
they're just timing out because I'm
running my streaming software I'm
running OBS so it's it's making
everything else slow okay
then let's just run a verifier
okay so what I just did there not you
don't really want to do this too much
but I bypassed the test it so I did a
manual commit I bypassed the tests
because I know that what we just did
should not mess up the test right we can
see that it's that it's working here
right all right so now let's check the
status and we'll do a git add and we're
gonna do a git commit and I'm gonna
bypass it again just so that because I
know the end end test will probably fail
just for timing reasons I'm trouble
spelling today and so then that the no
verify flag is that's what skips the
test and then the M flag is what allows
us to write a commit message in line so
we're gonna say
and we'll check the repo in a minute
when this gets pushed because we have
this you know what I take it back I was
gonna say we have the same test running
now with Travis on github but we
actually don't have the end end test
working yet with Travis so that that
wouldn't test but I was gonna say we
would have like a backup there we will
eventually rake huben says hi how often
do you use tomato time every day I use
it all the time even when I'm not
streaming I still time myself with it it
says he also says does it really work
yeah I think the Pomodoro Technique is
very helpful so I definitely recommend
it
darshan asks is jQuery a way to update
CSS elements or are there any other uses
of the same yeah you could update CSS
with jQuery you could also update CSS
with with regular JavaScript if you
wanted to and there are even ways to do
CSS with JavaScript in the context of
reacts there's actually a lot of
different ways to do it
Heidi says is it good to use frameworks
like react or do the job with CSS I
really like doing it with react and if
we were just writing like react
components and not having to deal with
all this like data that
is coming with this weird markup then we
would be doing all the CSS like in a
more react friendly way using one of the
variety of options out there for CSS and
react but because we have this kind of
unique situation where we're dealing
with data that's being pulled in we have
to do it I don't know that we had one of
the easiest ways for us to do it it's
just using regular CSS and linked style
sheets so I'm not saying that's the only
way but that's kind of the most
straightforward way for us to do that
right now and it is ultimately just a
temporary way to handle things for now
binary 64's is that next five point one
point zero actually I can't remember
what version we're running we have been
keeping things pretty up-to-date let's
check it out I believe I have my package
JSON open over here yeah so since I I
just pushed all that code to github
everything that we've done today is
available in the github repo so the
links in the description feel free to go
check it out you can use the code for
whatever you want it's open-source you
can even submit pull requests to this
project if you want to get some practice
in or help out where as a next yep five
point one point oh oh man he says don't
stop the live stream Jesse everybody
likes them I have no plans of stuff in
the live streams Alexander says keep on
with your last dreams I hire like hit a
lot cool yeah
I I'm pretty sure I've said this before
but I will continue to do live streams
one for as long as you all think that
they're valuable and helpful to you and
also as long as I can't like I have time
to right now my boss is very open to me
doing live streams like while I'm at
work either working from home or working
in the office as long as that doesn't
change it should be pretty easy to keep
live streaming if that change is gonna
be a little bit more difficult because
I'll have to do it outside of my normal
work hours I still want to keep it going
though I'd still like to make it work
but at the times that I stream will
probably be a little bit weird at least
for my timezone so the stream may be
like five o'clock in the morning so I
can get a stream in before all my kids
are awake or something like that
I be shik says thank you for for this
awesome tutorial oh you're welcome thank
you for watching and mammy says the good
thing is that we can ask questions at
the real time and Jessie answers us I do
my best to answer I don't know that I
always have great answers but I do my
best
there are a lot of the people in the
live chat that that know the answers and
give really awesome answers better than
I can give binary 64 says hey Jessie
have you tried necks with CSF hmm sorry
fro the yawning I'm gonna drink some of
my energy drink of choice G fuel and as
usual I am not yet sponsored by G fuel
but I'm open to it that was kind of a
running joke I'm only half joking though
seriously IG fuel sends me free stuff I
will talk about him every time I stream
okay I haven't so binary 64 I have not
used that yet I I will have to check
that out though because that sounds
awesome behind he says but setting that
darker value more than once feels dirty
yeah
binary says only ninety-six percent of
my country support hsla hmm I never even
thought about that so is that an issue
is a browser support for hsla an issue
for for a lot of browsers I haven't come
across it and what is their fallback if
that happens would it just fall back to
the default blue link color then or
could I do a fallback where I have like
two color values and one is a hex value
I mean I guess what would be the point I
should just translate that into hex
anyway
binary says did you do an NPM upgrade to
get next 5.1 how would I well yeah I
mean basically we use yarn so the
equivalent in yarn that's what we did I
pretty sure that's what we did
darshan says can you specify margins in
BR tag for a particular breaking between
two items yeah you you could you could
definitely style them you know however
you want Phoenix says BR tags are almost
appreciated or deprecated sorry and no
one uses them nowadays yeah yeah that's
what I mean normally you would just add
margins and things to your elements
directly and instead of putting those be
ours in between
I do see BRS like like WYSIWYG editors
sometimes add them automatically so I I
rarely see like code written by people
that has have a lot of be ours in them
I'll put them in like in email templates
and things because you kind of have to
use old-school stuff for email templates
anyway so like you you will still
encounter BR tags out there but normally
it's because they're auto-generated by
something but so if you do encounter
them then yeah you can style them
however you want but if you're creating
the HTML yourself then you probably
don't need them you're better off just
styling like whatever components that
you were gonna put the dip in between
instead just give those components the
margins or padding
see binary says can you take out those
BR tags after each item tag and move CSS
yeah I mean I could take out the tag so
I could either manually take them out
which would take too long right now so
I'm not interested in doing that right
now or I could use a function that when
the data comes in it just automatically
takes out all those tags but the easiest
way and what we're doing right now is we
just do display:none so if anybody wants
to look at the markup in dev tools it's
gonna look ugly but to the average user
who's not gonna bother to look at the
code there's no difference between
taking the break the BR tags out
completely or setting them to
display:none
I just read where Michael was calling
John mr. John so that's a while back my
daughter was on one of the streams I
Otis taught her and she she called John
mr. John binary says how does it get
from WordPress into next yes we we are
using graph QL so we have a plug-in
called WP graph QL that we were using on
the WordPress installation and then we
can call that that graph QL endpoint and
we can query that using Apollo so we
have Apollo running with next Jas with
react and so that we can we can query
that graph QL plug-in running on
WordPress it grabs all the data and
sends it to us so that's how we're
getting the data in so Lee says I'm
forced to just to use just the right
side headphone because I can't be
ignoring my wife I must make sure I hear
her I do the same thing sometimes I'll
just pop up like one side here so I
totally understand that
all right I got Auto to scroll down to
the bottom so sorry I'm trying to find
find that where I left off
yeah binary so binary is asking some
questions in Phoenix says you know that
they could just watch some of the older
streams which I mean that's cool
but I don't mind the questions because I
assume like there are probably more
people watching now and later on that
are also new the stream so I don't mind
explaining some of these things over
again because it'll probably be helpful
and I mean there there are a lot of
streams right now so it is gonna be
pretty crazy to watch them all maybe I
should try to do a better job of
explaining what's happening like maybe
write up something that can go in the
description to the video that's like
just a summary of what we've been doing
because even I mean I don't know that
I've ever actually done a full summary
in any of the streams so that might be
that might be good to do I probably
won't get to it today but I'll keep that
in mind as something that would be
helpful to do also I think the readme
file on the repo does have a little bit
more of an explanation as well so that
could be help for anybody that's that's
not sure what exactly we're doing check
out the github repo that's linked in the
description and the readme file that
comes up the first thing you'll see the
that'll come up does have a bit more of
a description of like what technologies
were using in
and what we're trying to do Mme says why
are you always testing on mobile sighs
so I like testing on mobile sighs
especially when I'm streaming for two
reasons the main reason is we expect our
audience to primarily use mobile devices
to view this site so I want to design it
while looking primarily at the mobile
view or the the really small screen size
that way I'll make the decisions with
that in mind if I did it at widescreen
like as much as I would try to keep in
mind the mobile it would not be the same
and what I would end up doing is putting
more on the page then can reasonably fit
on a mobile screen so it would always
feel like the mobile for you is is like
the secondary view but I want it to be I
want it to feel like the mobile view is
primary and then the desktop is the
secondary view so it's just kind of a
different way of looking at it I mean I
don't know that it's right or wrong it
just depends on your audience and what
what you expect what kind of devices
that you expect your audience will be
using primarily the second reason why I
do it
especially when I stream is because like
we can see you can see a lot more of the
dev tools here so I can make the font
size larger and it still works so it's
just kind of a practical way to do this
when I'm not streaming I can have this
spread out on two different screens so I
I could do full screen with the whole
screen and filled up with dev tool stuff
and it would be you know more doable
that way spar wheel says is it possible
to make this I just using HTML CSS and
JavaScript so any frameworks yeah for
sure yeah you could you could definitely
do that the trick
part would be though handling all the
routing so like we have client-side
routing happening so if you wanted
client-side routing like trying to make
that on your own it's a bit tricky and
then all the data like you would
obviously not want to hard-code
all that data that would be huge like
your code base would be insanely huge so
you would want to be pulling in the data
from somewhere so you would have to
handle that you know how are you pulling
in that data you know probably using
fetch so it would there would be a lot
of complicated things that something
like react handles for you and then the
same like if you're gonna pull in the
data with fetch search engines are not
gonna see that so are you gonna
server-side render on your own so it's
just like there's there's a lot of
things that at first sight it seems like
hey the site would be so easy to do with
HTML CSS and JavaScript well okay it
would except for these other things like
how do you handle all the data bringing
all the data over how do you handle
users who aren't don't know code editing
data how do you handle server-side
rendering how do you handle client-side
routing like there's all these other
issues that it's just like okay react
just makes sense here because it takes
care of so many of those other things
for us
let's see Darian Garcia says is this
being uploaded elsewhere because I'm not
seeing these questions on here I'm not
I'm not sure what you mean with so where
what what questions are you not seeing
and Darian says yes moving forward I've
read it's best to design mobile as first
and that's where the market currently
stands yeah yeah so I mean that's in
general I think it's safe to expect that
more and more people are gonna be
viewing the web primarily through a
mobile device but there are still some
instances where you may have users
primarily viewing your site on a desktop
like I'd say for instance if you were
designing an internal website for an
organization where everybody was in an
office setting and had computers like
desktop computers they may be more
likely since it's what they're used to
to just access work-related stuff on
their desktop computer so you check the
analytics and you know you may have a
situation where it's you know
overwhelmingly desktop users so
depending on you know whether people
want to view it on their phone or that's
anything desired then maybe you don't
want to do mobile mobile first
development for that so I mean there are
still some cases where you may not want
to but just in general I think the
mobile first development is the way to
go
and Nestle says you are too good thanks
you're welcome thanks for watching
I doc for the wind says I really want to
learn CSS and JavaScript oh yeah
definitely check out the free code camps
Oh Daria just said that all right it's a
good advice yeah check out free code
camp org and you can get free lessons
that'll start you out with HTML you'll
move on to CSS and then you move on to
JavaScript and we'll just keep building
you up and you can learn a lot just
through that it's a really good resource
and feel free to ask any questions if
you're ever watching this stream I'll be
happy to answer you answer your question
some of what we do will be kind of way
beyond if you're just starting out
learning it might be a bit harder I do
my best to explain it it looks like the
the stream health is not great right now
so I apologize if things are getting
choppy I I hope at least my voice is
still coming through alright since I'm
not really coding right now that's that
probably matters more than anything
which I make sense my kids just got home
from school so odds are one of them
started playing or attempting to play
some videos
see I dog says do I really need to learn
HTML first I already know that all right
no you can you can skip over so you
don't win free code camp you don't have
to do all the lessons right in a row you
can skip around so I don't know I'm the
type of person that I usually just start
from the beginning it's just like feels
right to me to start from the beginning
and I usually just fly through you know
the basics but occasionally I do pick up
some some piece of information that I
missed you know I just never knew and
maybe I had just forgotten so I usually
do get something out of the basics but
it's probably like mostly a waste of
time
so yeah that's entirely up to you
whether you want to go back through HTML
stuff or not but you definitely don't
have to
and it looks like Phoenix and Darian
also had similar similar thoughts there
about you know it really doesn't hurt to
go through the HTML stuff again even if
it's just a refresher oh Michael says
I'd I restarted and and beat free code
camp because it added some new things
cool yeah I'm gonna have to check out
the new stuff on free code camp as well
it's been quite a while since I've done
any of those exercises Darian says this
is amazing i subbed if you need help
with documentation I'm more than willing
to help just send me a ping okay cool
yeah you know Darian I definitely
welcome help for sure if check out the
repo and if there's any place that you
you want to help let me know maybe I'll
open up some issues having to do with
documentation you know I'm definitely
open with that and I'm open to help out
like help try to find somewhere for you
to contribute if you if you want to
divya says how much do you recommend to
learn vanilla JavaScript and then go on
with nodejs and react.js right now I
learned node and once a move on to react
or angular for please god I mean if if
you've already learned node then I'd say
you're probably fine to go into reactor
angular I mean I obviously prefer react
but there are a lot of people good
developers that use angular and build
you know cool stuff with it but yeah you
know I'll if you understand know then I
don't think react will be you know that
difficult for you to work through
let's see Michael says it's their way to
find out what files are importing a
function from another file like which
files in port from and
it Apollo I mean you should be able to
see let's let's check it out where's and
where is where is this another follow
where we have this
all right where do we have
there we are and I thought it was by the
queries okay so in Aneta Paulo
I mean we should be able to see
everything that's being imported should
be up here so we shouldn't be able to
use anything down here that isn't
already being imported from up here
and then if it's a particular function
from something up here then we would
need like so for instance like this in
memory cache so we're using in memory
cache dot restore so like the dot
restore obviously we're getting from
in-memory cache does that make sense
I'm mes is it possible to get a job
after completing free code camps running
certification
yeah people would people have done it I
would say I mean the important thing is
to make sure that you have a good
portfolio and I've really let built some
things contributing to open source
projects helps a lot and I mean applying
to a lot of places having a good resume
and a good like good connections really
helps oh there are a lot of other
factors that would go into getting a job
but in terms of learning the skills you
need to start building things your
front-end certification will definitely
give you a bunch of those skills and
then you'll pick up a lot more on the
job but yeah there are like on the free
code camp forums there are a lot of
people who have said that they've gotten
jobs after going through free code camp
so some of them just front end some of
them the whole thing like and everywhere
in between
hmmm he says right now have to complete
the advanced algorithms and the advanced
projects and it is going well I guess
but I don't know where to look in order
to get a job yeah I mean there's
checkout I think where I look Stack
Overflow Jobs has a lot of good job
listings for developers linkedin has a
lot of job listings so just between
those two places you'll find a ton of
jobs yeah I would I would try there
first than just everything that you're
even remotely qualified for applied to
even if you don't meet all the
requirements still apply because you you
never know maybe they won't get anybody
that meets all the requirements so it's
it's always good to try at the very
least you know if they give you an
interview even if you don't really have
a shot you'll get practice interviewing
you know you'll make some connections at
that place so it's always worth it to
apply
yeah so Michael yeah in terms of finding
out where all these things are I I don't
really know of any other way to figure
out where they're all coming from I mean
to me like as soon as I saw the question
I I just thought like hey we'll just see
where the import is stuff is coming in
and then that would at least point you
in the right direction where those files
are how many says thank you you're
welcome
you're welcome I hope that helps Michael
said the stream cut out when I was
starting to answer the question oh no
Michael you may have to watch the
recording then if you can't see this but
you know if you go into the Anita Paulo
das file and you check out everything
that's in the top here where it's
importing from you know then you can see
like where a particular function is
coming from like the restore function is
coming from the you know in memory cache
which is coming from the file called
Apollo cache in memory so and then if
you hover over that it actually shows
you where in the project that is so it's
within the node modules so that's that's
how I would go about finding stuff all
right and I've reached the bottom of the
live chat so here we're gonna come in
right at about an hour and a half for
the stream so I had I think I said we
were gonna do about an hour an hour and
a half so I guess I'm right on time here
thank you all for watching thank you for
all the help and advice and I had a lot
of great questions and answers in the
live chat today is Friday so I hope
you'll have a great weekend I will
probably be back Monday probably like in
a stream earlier in the day so maybe
like a morning stream for eastern time
zone
oh sorry so I you yes or I left I'll
work on that remind me in the next
stream about how to pronounce your name
correctly and I will definitely
definitely do my best to remember that
but anyway yeah again have a wonderful
weekend I will see you all on Monday